what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to g-eazy and hazely
performing him and i
right after hey
sorry hazley found out that g-eazy was
cheating on her
um
heard about this on tick-tock thought
it'd be funny to react to uh before i
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos as you guys know i'm
getting to england i'd really liked it
20 000 subscribers before i get there um
i'll do like a party or something i
don't even know
so yeah hit that subscribe button it
really helps me with the algorithm
all right i'ma start
we're back now with g-eazy and halsey
we've been waiting for this all morning
because the real life couple they're
climbing the charts with their hits and
they are adorable together uh by the way
now they're performing not for much
longer their duet off the rapper's new
album the beautiful and damned this is
him and i
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
and he is mine oh my gosh she looks so
pissed off
my 65 speeding up
a hell of a ride they don't want to see
us make it they just want to divide 2017
bonnie and clyde wouldn't see the point
of living on if one of us died
i wouldn't do that again look at look at
it i've been seeing bonnie and clyde
she's like
she's like don't touch me living on if
one of us died yeah
got that kind of style everybody try to
rip off why sell dress under when she
take the mink off silk on her body
ever catch me cheating she would try try
to cut my off
you see her laughing like she's oh she
knows oh she knows her i could never run
from her untouchables what she is no one
touches where we drive each other she be
so stubborn but what the hell is love
with no pain no suffer
incense it really gets dense she knows
when i'm out of feel like she could just
dance if i had a million dollars so it's
down to 10 cents she'd be down for
whatever never gotta convince
[Music]
he's like trying to hold her hand she's
like get off me
do you think the kids in the back can
feel the tension in the room
[Music]
she's like do not get too close to me do
not
[Music]
they identify my girl was the most solid
nothing to solidify she would never
teach you never see her with a different
guy ever tell you different then it's a
lie see that's my down chick see that's
my soldier she keep that thing thing if
anyone goes there to come and collect it
she keeps her composure and she gonna
ride for me i tell
[Music]
you know
[Music]
stay solid never lie to you swear most
likely imma die with your
[Music]
heart i swear
[Music]
i am
i will say her vocals are fire
considering she just got cheated on like
or found out
[Music]
oh my gosh sorry i'm eating
um
that was so funny
oh i'm sorry that poor girl that poor
girl
but
i was gonna say that's what happens when
you date a rapper but
i'm dating a rapper oh god
anyways let me know in the comments if
you like these type of reactions and i
will do more talk to you guys next